this is objectively a bad idea
delivering mail by having teenagers jump
off a moving boat run down a dock put
the letters in the mailbox then leap
back onto the moving boat before it
leaves them behind it's ridiculous i'm
not entirely safe and if someone
suggested it as a new thing now in the
21st century it would never be allowed
but male jumping is a summer tradition
here at lake geneva wisconsin usa and
it's also a tourist attraction and today
i'm going to get to see if i'd be any
good at it and it seemed like such a
good idea until i put the life jacket on
i have been male jumping for five
summers now this is my sixth summer at
the cruise line total but you have to
work here for a season and then you can
try out to be a male jumper now when
this started back in 1916 there was
about 60 houses on the entire lake and
that was the only way they can get mail
we deliver to about that same number
today we're not postal employees i'm an
employee of the cruise line we're
contracted to carry the lake mail for
that summer season which is june 15th to
september 15th so in 1916 the
predecessor of this company got the
mailboat walworth and started that daily
seasonal mail delivery around the lake
as you can imagine
our share of five cents postage from
1916 wouldn't have financed running a
boat like this and some forward thinking
person came up with the idea of making
this a passenger carrying mailboat
because that's really what covers the
cost of making these deliveries the
mailboat goes out every day at 10 a.m
even on sundays we do the sunday papers
i do this about three or four days a
week and there are six mail jumpers that
do this job if we get a big box to
deliver the captain will just slow down
a little bit just to make sure we don't
fall and hurt ourselves but if the
package is too big we will come to a
complete stop their shift starts at
seven so they start out by cleaning the
boat cleaning the bathrooms getting all
of the supplies on board paige has to go
through and get the newspapers all laid
out and the peer numbers on
so all these houses have like a street
address
but
we correlate that street address with
their peer numbers but we had about 15
kids try out for what ends up being
about five or six spots their mail
jumper and tour guide we have them do
some of the narration so we can hear
that they're articulate then we have
them do some jumps they have to be
somebody that's pretty athletic but we
let the tryouts pretty much sort that
out so i actually fell in when i tried
out for mail jumping but they let me do
it again and get a second chance so i
got to redeem myself you kind of just
have to be confident don't hesitate when
you're jumping because that's when
you're gonna slip and fall and get hurt
before we set off i did get some advice
from today's mail jumper so leaping off
do i need to like match speed with the
dock or anything like that it's not so
much about speed it's just making sure
that you're not like running at the boat
because otherwise it's just gonna
crash right into it so the jump off when
i'm leaving the boat it's just there's
the dock trying not to break your leg or
yeah
don't try to like jump and stop because
you're going to be moving again
obviously so try to like run it out a
little bit
also and then it's just so it's jump run
run run run run yes
it's going to be right there for you yep
put it in run run and then turn yep and
then take a few steps you know with the
boat okay so try and match vaguely some
speed with the boat and then it's leap
and grab yes okay
i'm going to say the woods how hard can
it be let's do it so i have fallen in
the lake a few times not so recently
though on the average probably once a
week or so somebody will go in the lake
most of the time when they miss they
miss coming back onto the boat so
somebody's outgoing mail might get wet
we've got a little pool skimmer down
below if we have to we've had somebody
lean out the door and scoop stuff back
up out of the lake the safety vests that
they wear are self-inflating the moment
they get wet
bang they blow up
every pier that we deliver to has a
ladder on it
and uh so when they miss they get
themselves back on the pier and i come
back around you know you you don't back
up to somebody that's in the water they
jump back on they wring out their socks
and we keep on going they know that
their mail might get wet someday they
know that their outgoing mail might have
tooth marks in it
i think this is a great summer job it's
really fun i like being out here on the
lake being out in the sun every day
right my turn the tourists have left the
team here are just giving me the same
test that they give to anyone trying out
for this job it is just that the people
who try out are usually half my age and
twice as athletic so
you know what could go wrong i'll
promise this i'm only giving myself one
attempt if i nail this you'll see it if
i miss the boat or chicken out on the
jump back you will also see it
this is all i need to do
you made that look so easy
i like that you you took the time to
kiss the goose on the like that was that
was style points this is an actual mail
right this is just this yeah that's just
a extra newspaper okay
let's let's do it
i just realized i'm still wearing my
microphone so i really do not want to
miss this jump
okay so when do i start going out i can
start yeah you can go ahead and climb
out okay
there's a little square up here that you
can put your left point
until you get ready to go all the way up
all right
the nerves just kicked in got it
and i want to leave with my right leg
out left leg back
okay
oh this is fast this is so much faster
than i thought it was ah
okay whoa
[Applause]
of all the ridiculous stuff i've done
the bit that scared me the most was the
landing just not no am i gonna just
collapse forward oh there's the goose
okay
i don't want to do that again
how many times do you do that paige
uh 40 50
times yeah thank you so much uh lake
geneva mailboat tours uh link's in the
description
going